hey what is up guys I'm Kay Bhd here and
first of all yes there is a ps4 in the
house a lot of people are asking so
thumbs up if you actually want to see me
cover that let me know but this is a
first look at a curved smartphone this
is the Samsung Galaxy round actually
personally a bit more excited for the LG
G flex because that seems way more
unique than this Galaxy round is as a
product but there's still a lot of
interesting things that we can look at
in the first available curved display
smartphone so not any further ado let's
go and take a full look so at first
glance the galaxy round actually doesn't
come off as all that crazy of a product
it seems like just your typical Samsung
smartphone in fact it looks like it's
older brother the Galaxy Note 3 quite a
bit it has that same 5.7 inch 1080p
AMOLED display on the front the same
faux leather stitching on the back
though a slightly different more brown
leather color and it really actually
shares a lot of the specs and hardware
with the Galaxy Note 3 like the
excellent 13 megapixel camera and the
flash you know what that's exactly what
this is a curved display galaxy note 3
I'll have my full galaxy note 3 review
right below that like button if you want
a refresher on how awesome that device
is but because this galaxy round is
curved it makes a few trade-offs and it
comes back at those with a few bonus
features so here are all the differences
between the galaxy round and the galaxy
note 3 number one is the backing the
back of the Galaxy Note 3 is obviously
flat and of course has that leatherette
stitching pattern we all know on the
back the back of the galaxy round is a
little different when you take it off
it's actually a bit more rigid more bent
into the curved shape of the round to
fit the back of the phone now it's
obviously still plastic it's not some
crazy new material or anything like that
it's very familiar but it's a little bit
more rigid because it's bent into that
shape now of course when you remove the
back you reveal numbers 2 & 3 that are
different the speaker and the battery
now the speaker is obviously it's just a
little bit bigger it fires out the back
of the phone instead of the bottom like
on the note 3 but the battery is a
bigger difference so it's actually a bit
smaller in fact it's a totally different
shape and it's shrunk down from 32
hundred milli amp hours to a tall
slender 2800 milliamp hours this is
because the phone is curved so you know
there's less room to fit a back
in the phone when you curve it like this
now even though that's only a relatively
small difference it's a 400 milliamp
hour difference now I still get all day
battery out of this phone with a twenty
eight hundred million power battery but
Samsung want the extra mile here to
bring us to number four which is the
included accessories Samsung bundles an
extra battery and a second battery
charger like an external battery charger
for this galaxy round that's why the box
looks so much bigger than the galaxy
note 3 box you get all these extra
accessories with it so this battery
charger it charges your secondary
battery by USB 2.0 you still can charge
the phones via a USB 3.0 but I mean
that's nice that's a nice touch I'm glad
they threw an extra battery in there now
another difference in accessories is the
obvious lack of an S Pen in the galaxy
round it's not part of the note line
technically but I mean it's also curved
so there's really not that much space to
put an S Pen so the next difference is
by the numbers the galaxy round is
technically a little bit thinner and a
little bit lighter than the note 3 but
not really by all that much it's it's
about more of the way it feels in the
hand it just feels slightly more compact
but that's not because of the thinness
and the lightness that's because of the
biggest difference between these phones
the display now again on paper it starts
off very similar they both have a 5.7
inch 1080p AMOLED display and they're
both gorgeous and very vivid and very
bright but the slight curve radius on
the round makes it stick out quite
literally the shape is actually really
slight very subtle almost seems like the
middle of the phone is still flat while
only the sides curve up a bit it's a
really interesting shape and after using
a phone for more than a week I'll tell
you what don't judge me I totally got
used to it you don't really notice the
curve when looking at the actual images
on the display after about a day or so
but you can still always feel the curve
with your finger and it feels nice now
this curve radius does a few things one
I think it actually improves the extreme
viewing angles by a tiny bit which isn't
particularly useful for a lot of people
but hey that's a thing that I noticed
and it also creates some weird
reflections to this day that distracted
me a little bit when I look over on my
desk and I see this warped reflection
looking back and make kind of strange
and number three it actually shrinks the
amount of stretching you have to do to
use this phone with smaller hands and I
feel like it made a significant
especially noticeable when typing typing
on this keyboard in the display is way
easier on the round than it is on any
other similar size splat smartphone now
the galaxy round has pretty much
identical software to the galaxy note 3
in the Korean market but Samsung threw
in this neat software feature called the
roll effect so basically when the phone
is sitting with the screen off you can
roll it onto its side and get a quick
glance at your notifications and the
time and the battery status it's
sensitive to the accelerometer too so
you can literally just lift it up
sideways and get the same effect
unfortunately it's hard for the phone to
determine when this is being done on
purpose so there's like a really solid
delay between you tilting the phone and
showing the preview and that sucks
because I think it's going to prevent
people from using it especially when it
doesn't take much more effort to just
simply tap the power button and check
your notifications the regular way but
besides all the Samsung gimmicky stuff I
am seriously a fan of using the galaxy
round I really enjoyed it I got judged
so hard on Google+ and Twitter for
admitting that I really am into this I'm
excited to see what other form factors
sort of emerge that we see in 2014 that
aren't the usual slab form factor you
should be too but yeah at the end of the
day when it comes down to it the curve
is quite subtle the actual curve radius
is a lot smaller than a lot of people
have made it out to look and a lot of
the images but it essentially feels a
lot like a slightly more compact galaxy
note 3 so I guess that makes it a pretty
well-rounded device in other words you
leave your comments down below and more
importantly I want to hear which one you
think you would like better the LG G
flex which curves vertically or the
galaxy round which curves horizontally
let me know in a comment below and I'll
be sure to get my coverage of the G flex
up soon and if you guys want the ps4
thanks for watching guys basically